foreign  s are being sadly wasted in this den of  imbecility  I got things to do mama needs tendon the  house needs cleaning I'm done pretending  that I can live in a Sim  ain't real  [Music]  what is it Cutting Edge VR Flynn  folks want me to pay to test it for a  shitload of money too  lay back close your eyes  count back from tan  [Applause]  [Music]  this is London  but London's 70 years from what you  think of as the president  [Music]  it's like being there in your body  you're inside peripheral  blood is in that body as if it were your  own  [Music]  [ __ ]  [Music]  I thought I was playing a Sim  it turns out if you prick us  we bleed  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]